okay four people joining this livestream
we are doing something supposedly simple
right now which is we are filling in a
guide page for documentation about
computer security features um
you
and what we want to do here is just list
off some of the things that we have in
the language that relate in some way or
another to computer security so I figure
the first step is encryption um
and maybe people could respond to this a
bit so I think we also have a file hash
function do we not
does that seem more relevant than just
hash maybe it is it's some what do you
think I mean think about how we would
actually be using this I would say in a
topic if you shape your security file
hash for practice is more usable but
then this if you are listing file
Hashemite lease hash as well because
they're like browsers you know no I
understand but the question is should I
list
okay maybe what I'll do here is on this
line I will list file hash okay okay is
there anything else in this collection
that is okay so first of all with
encryption I think we've got
that is the basic stuff we need there
yes
is that right I mean I'm looking at the
cryptography guys page to see if there's
other ones we have um yeah
encrypt file you have oh and actually by
the way I need to refer to the
encryption guide page there I mean I
need to link that to encryption page
what does it call what's the encryption
sage guides cryptography yes I think the
main one okay in the zoom chance no that
won't help me because the way the
linking works here that won't help me um
that one okay at least that's what I'm
looking at right now right okay so what
what page is relevant for verification
and signatures is that that same pager
is at a different page not sure we have
one Daria do you you mean for digital
signatures I mean digital signatures is
a section yeah okay maybe you want to
put it the other way around signatures
and verification okay I mean I wrote
what's here
dreamily quickly as kind of a skeleton
but Tim okay let's take a look at what's
on this page okay now things like
password cracking go ahead - is hash on
this page should it be don't see it's
right there okay sorry okay so let's
let's point this
I'm afraid this probably is still it's
all gonna have to point at the same page
it's all gonna point at that encryption
page right all those links are gonna
point at the encryption page I think the
cryptography page will grow over time
and hit me may wanna split it up but
right now it says it's right assumable
links I think okay um and then we want
to link back from the cryptography page
to this computer security page I wonder
whether we want to call it computer
security over the world to call it
something like what did I just do that
did I do the wrong thing there Brow's or
do we want to call it something like
functions computer security
functionality or something okay key
management just going to point to that
same page again right I think so yeah
on the live stream
fiestar's asking got an AE ad what is
that sure fact we don't know what it is
not a good sign but that's a carrier do
you know
I don't know antiquated encryption what
is that I don't know what that is
let's take a look is that just the term
off of a number of functionalities
that's oh this business may be a
reference to like the new cipher suites
in in like TLS one two like poly ChaCha
and and the elliptical curve stuff well
but but one of the questions here so I
don't know what this is this is a daria
question Daria can you comment on this
and this seems they could be a very
general saying which is like it's not a
given encryption you provide a password
doing encrypts and then I think we have
this I might have to look to more
details of this but it seems general
enough like we have generate symmetric
key beta and a password we have
generally derived key Bane on your
password and those you use for it so one
point here is that the you know the key
words on these pages need to include
things that allow people to find I mean
if we do have this in some way then they
need to be able to find it by um you
know with key words
yeah I mean if anything the encrypted
file function would be the place where
you should be able to specify what kind
of cipher suite and integrity you want I
mean all the the protocols that I news
on the web or for
SSH and so on that's a big deal you
specify the cipher and you specify the
kind of Mac you want and I'm not I don't
know I mean I don't know whether we have
that in the encrypted file or not
I don't think we do I mean the other
thing we don't have an encrypt which I
thought Daria was working on is priming
it with public key and then going to
something else for large files right
tutorial yes but that is like I have not
started working on that yet but for the
thing that was mentioned just before
about selecting the cyber encrypt you
select the cipher when you generate a
symmetric key you generate the key for a
specific cipher and then you couldn't do
it crypt and so this way you selected
the same you want encrypt and block mode
and other things beside I understand but
this this authentication think we need
to understand I don't understand this I
mean you know when we say generate you
know if we say generate symmetric key
open closed then that will be by default
a key for this cipher right so and and
the problem is when we generate a
symmetric key pair we may have to
specify both the what am I saying we may
have to specify both some the sort of
public key part and the private key part
that runs for large files by making
sense all right anyway but but who who's
going to take on making sure that we
actually go through these pages and make
sure that we understand what key words
we should be adding if indeed we're
already doing this stuff who can who can
it'll be me and Aria and Karla and
classified okay all right let's keep
going okay so here what other stuff for
key management do we have to mention
this stuff that we will be mentioning
for the system key chain it's going to
be part of that key management section
is that correct
well the keychain doesn't itself have
any cryptography right I mean it stores
oh I know but this is about key
management I mean yes we management is
so so we should have an entry about the
authentication dialog and system
credential as soon as that is ready okay
but so this will be done in
authentication or what where where
should we be putting the section on key
management okay so but but
authentication we've listed here as a
separate thing I may have got it wrong
but but you get what I'm saying yes I
mean that's the you think we should move
or medication up to to a section up here
no what I mean is we have we will have
functions to securely store credentials
so whatever you need for the
authentication here is something you can
then store in a keyring I understand I'm
asking in terms of the page even should
the keyring functionality be up here
with key management or down here with
authentication well it's for I mean it's
not that kind of key management we have
that generates keys but it's certainly
relevant to make bookkeeping and care
and feeding of keys I don't know whether
that's coded up yes
just put the Futurist or blue entry
force just wide system credential then
we know what to do so what we let's just
understand the description system
credential store keys in what are the
water go around these yes store a store
securely store authentication data or
something like that but but isn't there
aren't that functions that go around
this there's not just system financial
there's other things on there or do you
know it's missing credential you say
system credential or foo equals secret
okay okay I think this should be a
separate I think there should be a
separate section about system I think
this is a different thing I think this
is a section about system key management
or something system
keyring I don't know what the keyring is
the right term what's the right term
here I mean there's keying is used
frequently then there's key chain that
is used okay
use use use your computer systems use
you use securely store credentials
within your operating system yes that's
a it's a good description using
operating system services keys key
services or that bad term I mean I some
are calling key rings some are calling
key chains so yeah I mean it depends on
whether you're Mac and Windows and I
understand did this is the key chain
link project from constants yes yes so
we're talking about different backends
as well that we're gonna support so does
it mean that doesn't belong here with
the documentation for system credential
will touch Stevens asking like what else
yeah
using operating system services is that
right I mean I mean I don't think this
page needs anymore
okay but should this be under system
what else goes with that with operating
system I think this is um see there are
things that are about your computer
system there are other things about your
computer system I mean something which
is very specific but is of the same kind
is the kind of SSH agent which would
allow you to maintain SSH passwords for
logging into it okay well so I think
that should be but let's not look that's
not hook to avoid from language so it's
kind of fixed right but we also need to
talk about the SSH mechanism yes and so
I think that that becomes a section that
really is this is well I'm not sure I
mean we have yes we have copy files
which can securely copy files to remote
systems
I don't know whether you want to put
them under external operations when you
have dollars SH authentication but
that's not the right entry point so tell
me I'll be fine list e okay my copy file
is can be used to securely access remote
files using SSH and other protocols ok
copy file so um
securely access remote remote resource
note files copy remote files using SSH
etc you know when we have a remote file
function-- right that's that's a
low-level one that's usually not visible
how do we have remote fast I know it's
in it's in 12 right the if you go to ref
remote file oh yeah it's it's wet but
it's a weapon so that's a copy copy file
of something and I yes that's a secure
copy and a secure copy right remote file
is a web that allows you to embed
credentials you need to access the file
and it seems highly relevant to be fine
okay yes so let yes remote file is yes
right yes remote file is how do you
create it's the same kind of thing like
fine it's a wrapper right symbolic
representation of a remote file
including credentials okay that yes
that's good and there's also a remote
connect hold on hold on remote file
including credentials okay then we don't
really have to say um okay then I guess
we probably should put that first here
but maybe this should be really called
external files I mean the question is
you see I mean just what Donna said I
mean we have remote remote one and so on
so question is how you one section
separate sections or could you put both
sound or external operations
that's a remote run I said remote
connects but yeah remote run and remote
run processor also remote connect and
remote what is remote connect the that
connect that gives you a remote
connection object that's a
representation of a remote host you know
yeah it's such it's SSH and boy from
language it lets you run remote
processes I super okay so so this H yeah
so let's use I don't we call this secure
file operations and then say then have a
separate thing saying the moat process
yeah see yeah over stick over SSH or
over over secure connections that's
that's I'll operations yeah okay I don't
know there any other secure file
operations and then we have a separate
section here which is um secure remotes
processes source secure remote process
communication but then secure remote
suggestion secure remote access okay
well um you can delete that all our ssh
authentication that's really just a
default for a foreign that for an
authentication option I don't think
that's very trying to copy file why
isn't that relevant it gives people a
sense of what's going on well that's
okay yeah it's better down there yes
okay fine
secure file okay so secure remote access
removing copy file from here so this is
the first thing here is remote connect
is that right yeah okay what's the
just sets up a connection to a remote
machine that you can then use for set up
an SSH connection is that right yeah I
think so yeah
zero is SSH kanji yes okay set up a
secure connection let's just says secure
connection to a remote host yeah
and then once you do that you can do for
example remote run process okay so I do
I need to list those separately oh can I
just list those that's pretty obvious
what's gonna go on there you can do you
can you know with the dots remote run
remote or in process toast those are two
to the two you want
are there any others for remote run
process is there any other process
control that comes with a remote run
process well you can do write line and
read string you can do write line to
your remote to your remote connection
object and then you know there's the
string of a command it's the second
example there's an example down there go
down down down down down oh no no no see
where it says oh sorry sorry I thought
go to the remote connect page and then
look at the example uh yeah there's a
write line and read string you know you
can just write and that should be
secured before it goes over the internet
that seems useful okay the point is that
the PW do with the you know the string
PWD there will be encrypted and and the
stuff that comes back right right like
if you're in a coffee shop nobody can
you know yeah nobody listening on that
they say okay okay I understand point
yes is there any other file operation
here that we that we need for other any
other well I mean there are further down
this you are wheat and your URL download
is probably relevant because you are a
download supports
all the same secure protocols but only
on the source side for reading from okay
all right so look what next we have are
we dealing with web operations next and
then we should have a section for it I
think we should put I think we should do
this there was a there's a typo for a
remote file from the stream it should be
symbolic I'm station of a remote file
I'm not cute and there's one more typo
remove including where maybe you already
fixed that but you probably already
fixed it okay all right so now let's see
do we want to now talk about I mean at
some point we want to talk about web
security but we want to talk about that
in several different ways I mean do we
want I'm a little confused maybe we
should have the authentication stuff up
above after encryption then we go to
authentication then we go to what we you
can actually do like these file
operations get what I'm saying I mean
these all say ok no so yeah you are
right I mean because the top percent
equation is not relevant but although
Isis a chose education if so in
authentication comes before doing
anything just conceptually okay so
various comments on the live stream
about multi-factor authentication um let
me just read some of these santur
comments that he submitted veneer cipher
and and oh great I mean I do think at
some point that we should add to
generate symmetric key we should add the
the things maybe using functional posit
or e code from for things like Caesar
ciphers just for fun just because people
can use them for cryptography classes
and so on
better not be the case that anybody uses
that for a real application otherwise um
ok ether necessary is an interconnect to
remote machines via a jump host in AWS
for a multi factor since this currently
is impossible in v2
of integrating more advanced ssh support
with radicals is very very important
anybody who wants to use remote GPUs ok
we'd like to know what the top priority
issues are there Ethan is asking what
happened to Colonel launcher and friends
Roman that's that's the kernel
configuration yes I mean they the
current remote kernels for para
computing use very old-style
ssh operations and a new version of that
that is suitable for all of these modern
things like computers services
supercomputers is in the works and
should be well will be in one of the
next bursts ok the SSH stuff like port
forwarding which is required for these
setups by the way is that in Sushma's
roadmap documents this do we consider
that that's a big enough project that it
should be in there this this project I
mean the kernel configuration manager is
that what this is about the kernel
configuration right so it's part it's
part of it test so this is this is easy
ok great
ok and multi-factor authentication is
that something for us to deal with or is
that something that gets dealt with a
little different it's a different place
I'm not sure how that works well I mean
there's several I mean one is sauce I
mean there we probably just support
whatever whatever it supports but but I
mean the multi-factor stuff for its you
know texting a phone and junk like that
yes I mean there are I'm aware there are
situations where SSH will require a
second facto and at the moment this is
not not possible because we do not allow
any interaction during the actual
communication setup but so you're saying
that there are systems which in order to
ssh into them require two-factor
authentication yes question is whether
we have the plumbing to expose that
second factor during the ssh process is
that right no we do not have a mechanism
for intercepting
during day you think about of course
what you can do in such a case is you
first establish manually establish
connection from your terminal and use
connection sharing and then everything
out of what does that mean it's just an
SSH option and then the SSH that you
have will act as a server and whenever
you make a second connection to the same
host it will piggyback on the existing
connection and not require any nukem any
new credentials okay do we have a
workflow that tells people how to do
that
not yet but that's a very good idea
let's have all on two-factor
authentication okay Carla please make a
note for me um I wonder for folks for
Ethan on the live stream I wonder
whether what Roman just described
whether that would actually solve your
problem um okay let's keep going here so
we're now doing okay um how should we
what what are the things that we need to
describe here in this authentication
section or is it the
wrong section I mean I you know I'm not
guaranteeing this is the right section
ah let's see
specify authentication
well it's the authentication option
option of Education option
cloud web and SSH operations
is that reasonable anybody comments
please yeah I'm more lessor I was
looking other other functions like you
wanna mention Cloud Connect in this
context or do you want to do that
somewhere else or what want to mention
Cloud Connect down here presumably okay
I didn't mean to get you off track there
and now that you have authentication
listed there the dollar ssh
authentication okay let's just
understand what we're putting in this
section this is about that this is that
option okay now we have to say how to
get the password you know the password
dialog what is that called that is
authentication dialog right yes and that
is bring up a variety of authentication
dialogues right is that correct yes well
not sure to dismiss describe it I mean
it's it's the it's an interface for
configuring any sort of authentication
dialog wait a minutes it's a okay so he
to actively request credentials yeah
okay authentication credentials that
seems about right okay okay
now what's next so now we've got the
various forms of things like permissions
key but permissions key is a creature
only of our cloud permissions correct
thinks
yeah yeah cured authentication key is
the OAuth symbolic representation of
orphan other yeah okay now what else
should be here generate secured event
do we have that no we don't that's
important okay so here okay and then
there's also secured authentication keys
which is that's from managing oh boy I
mean that's really a thing for cloud
right that's for managing authentication
keys is that correct
tells us for our own authentication keys
is that right yeah it's just a list of
keys that you have but but is that
outgoing keys that you have to use on
other systems or is that um did you get
what I'm asking
yeah I'm thinking I'm thinking okay so
isn't generate secure authentication
that's something to generate keys to
access our system right no no the exit
like look at the example right this is
like to access the Flickr service so
this is generate security authentication
key no that's for generating ones for
our prosper for accessing us that's for
accessing us yes all right is there
anybody else who can help me I'm getting
confused here sorry it's I'm pretty sure
that's um that's equal authentication
key is generate Keith generate key for
OAuth access
this is then this permissions key is
symbolic representation of an app ID
style key now I think I don't really
have the right people here I mean we
also supporting basic auth and things
like this but I really want to get on to
these other more general
okay so ssh authentication you tell me
is irrelevant
yeah that's assumed by authentication
it's just a default value of the option
for ssh functions i still want to put it
in because it's what is it for I mean
it's useful to people to know yeah if
you say let's see what is it I have to
have to try it out first oh yes look at
the options of remote files and you see
how it works
okay familiar paradigm of delayed
default value okay so we should where
should we put this we should say right
below authentication okay default
defaults for ssh authentication
yes that's good should we call this
curity related functionality yeah
computer security usually is about
hardening your machine against attacks
well I know but but but this is also
going to contain things about um you
know packet analysis and so on down here
yeah and does it contain discussion of
our sandbox no but I don't know how what
are the functions around the sandbox I
don't know is it exposed to not it's
just it's being exposed I don't know if
it's fully exposed yet does anybody know
if we have the wrong people I don't
think it's documented very well at all
you mean that's part of stuff this
sandbox mode now it's not documented no
okay all right I mean we yeah it's all
in developer context that's the other
program all right
so system key chains so now isn't there
also stuff where you're storing things
in okay so wait a minute this is
okay the way it works is that if you
have operating system Kealing and 99% of
Windows and Mac users will have one then
it's a zero configuration it will just
use that if you click that box to
remember your credentials and if there
isn't one then we now have this
encrypted file back-end but that's just
a hack for those cases where there is no
system clearly so I don't think we need
to okay do we want to do we want to talk
about another thing about your
persistent storage stuff here is that
relevant
I mean system code engine is a way of is
a kind of persistent storage for
sensitive information but persistent
storage itself has no security okay okay
so we don't want to okay let's few tries
that then okay let's go on to the cloud
here cloud permissions um so this is
detailed permissions options for cloud
objects but Cloud Connect is something
yet different isn't it it's kind of
yeah I mean it it locks you into the
cloud right so and then I don't know so
it's just like remote remote run process
or so it establishes a state I mean
maybe this section shouldn't be called
cloud permissions but something more
general you know everything to do with
the Wolfram cloud like connecting
securely or interacting with the Wolfram
cloud you know in a secure fashion it's
not just about permissions that section
it's about we have all from clouds right
who can do what's right that's all
security your latest right so who has
access to cloud objects you know okay
how do you set up a connection to the
cloud securely I mean that's all related
to okay authentication control or
something you know is that right the
right term Oh Santa cases are going it's
good enough ok ok ok here ok um
login to the Wolfram authenticate to the
Wolfram cloud to a Wolfram cloud you
know with your user ID and your password
to our open cloud
ok now maybe underneath here we want to
list um you wanna list cloud disconnect
to disconnects dollar cloud connected
probably dollar Wolfram ID yeah we might
want to list some of those things I know
it isn't it's cloud user ID dollar cloud
user ID cloud base
yeah I think it's relevant yes
um a change
okay okay now permissions detailed
permissions for cloud objects okay set
permissions and we've also got
permissions groups and all those kinds
of things and there is a cloud
permissions control guide page I'll put
it on for you
permissions um okay that's fine okay
here we want to have you know what I
think we shouldn't bother to list this
in detail here we'll should point people
to other places for this um so we want
set permissions permissions group just
to tell people that we have those this
creates permissions group so we have had
users remove user set users okay so
that's all for permissions groups right
yeah and then there's permissions groups
with it ending in a letter s like I
understand to understand so let's say
let's say permissions group add user
what's the called add user add users
remove users and set users it's all
related to coops permission groups right
okay do you think we should list is
there a clear
emissions as well as the set permissions
No okay I mean what do you mean clear
permissions so set permissions is a
function for setting permissions of a
cloud object right there is yeah so yeah
there is a clear but I'm sorry I also
have been the wrong yeah there is a
clear permissions sorry what scholar
permissions oh that's the that's some
details that's the mask what's the call
you mask it's it's the default
permissions for a new cloud object right
okay then we've got these things here
permissions key which I think we have to
list separately because I think it's
relevant to understanding okay I think
that's it for this yeah well there's
yeah there's permission keys and deletes
permission key and I probably don't want
to repeat everything that well wait a
minute permissions Keys like like under
permissions key right you can do it the
dotted line where you have permission
keys and delete permissions key yeah we
could just let
it's incomprehensible what these things
are unless I'll tell you what let's do
this um me you want to point to the
guide page if possible there's a guide
page called cloud permissions control
yeah okay well then maybe we should say
so maybe split off this stuff at the top
there see on the clock we often cloud
okay maybe we say Wolfram cloud
authentication that's not really right
our authentication and then we say
Wolfram cloud permissions been is asking
the live stream is there a way to set it
to things like cloud put default to
public instead private yeah you set
dollar permissions I think I think so
too so that can be a link to their cloud
permissions control guide page okay
in that guide page does mention Cloud
Connect but at the very bottom so oddly
enough okay okay alright I don't know
whether this is is this relevant to have
the permissions key and all the stuff so
emphasized here should be not bother
think it's relevant because it's
relevant to knowing how you deal with
all these weird tokens and so on you see
what I'm saying
yeah I think it's fine sir okay all
right so now we've got we're down to web
operations right here I've got secure
file operations now we do down to web
operations and then we're going to be
talking about um the other things that I
can think of here oh you know what else
we need
oh yeah we have that um what other kinds
of things okay let's go through a um
like cookies and so on we need to talk
about that and host lookups and web
execute and so on okay let's talk about
web security first what what do we want
to see that well
HTTP is the one that's secure nut I mean
I understand I mean gory but we want to
talk about URL being able to use URL
read and so on securely right yeah
so how do we what do we want to say that
you are all read you are which one do we
want to which one is the main one URL
read probably okay as opposed to URL
execute sure okay um and here read from
a URL with or
education because it's going to be the
authentication option that lets you do
that right I'm not sure I think I would
emphasize HTTPS I mean you can read from
I mean you can read securely from URLs
that I think that's pointed that your
authentication is a little bit okay um
well but that's a separate thing it
means that you can read securely from
the URL now does the URL wrapper include
authentication can you put an
authentication option in the URL wrapper
not yet but that's under consideration
in analogy to remote fine okay
read securely allowing authentication
sure okay now when you do that URL read
um I mean there's also URL execute which
we probably want to mention but we also
HTTP request and response those things
can be set up I think we should just
list here URL execute and then HTTP
request HTTP response because you can
pack authentication into those right I
think so yeah I mean it didn't yeah I
mean for example if you want to put
headers in security sorry I'm just hung
up on the HTTPS cuz that you know like
we like everything is either HTTP or
HTTPS and and you know like both are
supported but on a page where you talk
about security right you want to
emphasize HTTPS okay that so I
understand okay so what do you want to
say do you want to change this no no no
no it's fine I just want to yeah okay
so what else do we need to say here so
what's all this stuff about verify
security certificates and so on what do
we want to say so that's that's after
webste that's how the web server
identifies itself right so I think by
default we don't verify it and if we do
or not but you can't verify dilution to
verify web server certificates
right yeah okay so what other security
related options are there for loops and
then we're gonna get into cookies in a
minute see because this
username and password doesn't it this
allows that to be specified if I
remember correctly follow redirects
isn't that a security related thing mmm
I assume let's just following the 302 is
right 302 through 301 okay that that
standeth I mean that's fine you clearly
there's no problem okay so here I
thought there was a way of giving yes
there is a way of giving um okay fine
all right
okay service connect
um so this is really a yet separate
thing accessing external services um as
far as I know are always over HTTPS well
but that's not the point I mean access
so external services without allowing
with authentication let's let me know in
the authentic
can be through a you know like this Oh
auth authentication all right
yeah like three-legged often things yeah
there's this you know if you do like
surface connect of Twitter common new
right it opens the web browser and you
know yeah right right you you give
permission in the web browser and then
it automatically adds three-legged OAuth
yeah okay we call the secure web
operations assistant yeah if you want to
start to work I don't know what do you
what do you want to say here I think we
want to say secure web operations um
okay we need a link for both this and
external services so the external
services I just don't know where it is
there's accessing external services and
api's it's I got it okay I'm will need
links for those other ones as well um do
you want the right now would be nice but
well I'm gonna run out of time here and
I really want to go through what other
types of things we have here okay so
this is now we've now got encryption
authentication secure files now these
things like security options we also
want blockchain okay maybe we'll put
blockchain at the bottom what do you
think after all these security off and
then we want the security analysis stuff
right which it to me is yes a separate
issue
am I making sense
okay so where do we put I think we'll
put blockchain where should we put
blockchain is kind of like an
application area right like an extreme
nervous is that a reasonable yeah Dario
was saying something I was saying that I
think it makes sense for blockchain to
go in the bottom because really like
security agencies watching are watching
team called any transaction sign no no
but the whole idea of blockchain is it's
all about you mean you may want to put
them accessing external services also
lower as you know because of the
application area you know like the
application area has come last yea but
web operations is it's so similar to web
operations okay that's just a suggestion
okay so in blockchain what do we have
that is directly relevant to this we
have the whole blockchain transaction
sign all that kind of stuff right okay
so I think we say blockchain but I mean
the whole
idea of you know blockchain put
blockchain get should be on here because
this is relevant to you know how you do
security and making sense
I would have thought what other
operations um blockchain block data dot
dot dot well might as well be bulk Jim
address data because an address is
either your or somebody else's public
well but this is something different
this is just using a blockchain
blockchain put to do security as opposed
to okay so you're saying blockchain
address data should go here shouldn't we
also have blockchain token data because
that seems relevant to security I don't
know you tell me I mean as a whole this
time eNOS I mean every single block
shape the function can be listed here in
spy I know that but I'm trying to get an
idea of what okay I think that's okay if
people think that's okay yeah um and
then I look to the blockchain page I
just had a thought about the encode
function do we listen anywhere like to
end coach or no we do not
that's a good idea not sure I know what
fits maybe with files you know if
coach or your code to understand um
Crypt file I don't want to put it in
here that because it really isn't as
close to that as some and of course the
language actually you know go ahead I
mean what we could do here is um have
something called language level
functions or code you know code security
secur secur in your code
I mean way of like read protected locks
you know like attributes to protect your
code yes yes yes local code security
yeah it's a good point
read protect well isn't there a function
read protect read protected no I
understand but how do you do protects
this protect protect on a symbol sets
the attribute protected yeah read
protected you attribute say that to be
yes okay but I think local code security
um set a symbol to be write protected
right and then we can list here
that was a good cat
those things should be in here um so we
want protected and read protected here
and locked is that the important one if
you yeah yeah you want to lock things
down really hard okay and then we want
to encode and decode right encode
definitely encode yeah and get
presumably decode yeah right right right
right
encode code encode packages code source
to I think yeah
encode source to be to require a
password and get us the decoding unless
you gave it a key if you gave it a kid
ain't and get has to take that key
well we're encode source encode source
code the password is optional allowing a
with optional password yeah okay and I
would
argue that we should also put in here um
we should put get and we should put dump
save here stump say there's a sort of
related operation I wonder whether we
should put anything about wxf what is
binary serialized might go here as well
I mean it's not really in you know am I
making sense yeah that's a very open
format though like as long as you follow
the instructions you can anybody I
understand but it's not it's not
readable on its face yeah okay now what
about all the attributes
what about documents security notebooks
security that has to do with things like
come with notebooks sign or something
what does it call this is not book sign
I don't think so I don't think we have
been fully implemented
yeah what what's the signing there's
there's a function that does CDF signing
or anything like that yeah that's
internal um but but what there is the
things about editable false and all
those kinds of things you know editable
what what are the other things around
that elite of all selectable there's
deploy what is that - I kind of it's for
things like controls kind of locks down
areas it's not it's not foolproof by any
means okay no let's get a good link for
that okay all right let's go here CD a
CDF deploy is the one there does signing
I think is that right brain but that
isn't a built-in function is it yeah oh
yeah okay I see you like securely take
takes your CDF file and it adds signing
to it I think
I'm not mistaken doesn't this need to be
modernized well it was modernized and it
looks like it was what touched an 11-2
so what that says down there yeah okay
so nobody has to say CDF deploy here um
no we can verify that that's correct but
it's I think I think it applies signing
- its - to sign a notebook or deploy a
notebook to be used by notebook player I
think so yeah I mean isn't that the
function it allows manipulates to work
and things like that saying a player
right I mean yeah if there's a that what
that would be the functional or file
safe SCDF might does that exist anymore
well there's file okay listen let's keep
going here because we've got other
things these reads them okay so we've
got blockchain we need to link to that
okay security options for the product
itself allow Internet access
so I'm saying that these are you can set
that right allow Internet access
correct I think so I'm looking on they
said a document symbol though I don't
see it maybe I'm wrong it's in there
it's in the Preferences there's a low
Internet I think that's dollar allow
Internet okay I'm mistyping connection
settings
is that is that even documented in URL
read is that something want to put on
this page
that's more like Network debugging
yeah that's to do with like throttling
speed and things like that so a dollar
allow Internet excuse me we do not have
connection settings on this page growl
how did that happen um could you Brian
could you look into this please I'm
sorry
connection settings should be as listed
option on URL read definitely there
would be for me and Karla and for him to
take a look at okay I'm gonna put
connection settings on here but there
are other functions to put it onto as
well I'm making sense
that's a goof I still don't see a dollar
allow Internet
okay what's the default for connection
settings allow internet yes definitely
okay wait a minute
the dollar will our internet is in the
packet man yeah text that's why I
couldn't find it
oh really okay so what other securities
I mean the dollar network-connected is
the computer connected to a network but
I don't know whether what about okay
what about Dolan network interface is
all that kind of thing that's not
security that's more yeah it's more
information alright it's not okay okay
so so dollar allow Internet access isn't
a thing except the preferences is I know
how we indicate that here um you've got
to have the Preferences menu mhm
I mean we should should hunt this down I
mean if there is a preference setting
for all our internet there should be
language yeah so you know we may simply
pull that all our internet into system
context so but that's something for the
packet manager people to look at well
we're gonna be working on the backup
system this year so hopefully it'll pop
right out of the project something to
keep in mind I think the front end has
its own notion of whether internet is
allowed as well but that's not anywhere
exposed it's all hidden that's hidden
somewhere in front end context just
something to keep in mind when you're
digging through this um okay listen
we're gonna have to wrap this meeting
and this means we're not quite done here
okay I mean a few tries these sections I
mean I'm gonna put this thing I'm going
to defeat rise this page um we also have
to knit to this page Brian you need to
remind me of that or maybe we shouldn't
do few tries um but we got to do
knitting or gonna finish this page it's
gonna take another hour and I you guys
need to think about what other things
should go on here like the cookie stuff
and so on right yes
you understand no you don't understand
yeah sorry now I was thinking yeah and I
don't know you know look topics here
will be things like you know port
scanning
how do you do port scanning with socket
connect presumably am I making sense
finding cookies that have been set what
other topics are there here network
scanning what other topics are there I
think it would depend on how broad you
want to get something like see SSH
clustered SSH is very useful but
definitely not something that's
supported okay but that's not what I'm
talking about here is security analysis
things out we're done here yeah yeah
your hearings definitely useful which we
can do right we have you know we have
things like ping ping time I don't think
pink time is quite the same thing I mean
we could we could imagine listening ping
time well you can use it to see if there
are certain machines active on a certain
IP address right that's true but what
I'm talking about is that isn't socket
connected to thing you need for port
scanning I have never done that probably
yes but I've never done it so I mean
would you just put a port number on it
yeah I mean presumably you'd want to do
something similar to nmap I think I
think if I did that then I would ever
see anybody in my office you know okay
come on come on we're trying to make a
list of things I wonder whether we
actually reference anything no but we
have that functionality and by the way
that index should have found something
like that
okay so this is what I want you guys to
think about right is what other
functionality do we have that somebody
would use to check the security of their
system right so network packet capture
one good thing you know other random
packets flapping around
well I maybe I can set up a meeting to
go to brainstorm one that's been a
subset of people there something like
what SSL labs
or security headers comm telling you oh
hey you you have you know TLS 1.2 on
that's not a good thing anymore or SSL
version 3 or real things like how do we
how do we do that we do that because we
can read the headers right well in that
particular case you could do that with I
thought I saw something with verifying
the security certificate which yes which
you could talk about significant types
and what you should or shouldn't do
there and then yeah if you're doing a
connection to just a you know any random
web server you you can definitely try to
connect with other insecure options to
see if the server will allow you to do
so and it should not but and you know if
it does then then you could say oh hey
that's the problem okay all right okay
fine you guys need to brainstorm this I
think we're we're out of time for this
meeting please set up something to
continue and yeah thanks all to be
continued thanks to folks on the
livestream right well soon okay bye bye